written and directed by Christopher
Nolan and starring kellyanne Murphy
Oppenheimer is one of the most
historically accurate Blockbusters ever
made but it still had to gloss over and
omit some extraordinary details here's
how close it got to the real deal
perhaps the most notable character in
Oppenheimer that isn't named Oppenheimer
is Louis Strauss played by Robert Downey
Jr upon meeting Strauss Oppenheimer
remarks that he can relate to the fact
that Strauss is a self-made man as his
father was too the two also briefly
commiserate about anti-Semitism
otherwise the film doesn't delve too
deeply into oppenheimer's childhood
Robert's father Julius was a German Jew
who fled to New York City in 1888. he
really did start with nothing and he
turned a job at a textile Factory into a
lucrative business Empire the family
wasn't religious as Julius and his wife
Ella sent their children to a
progressive institution called the
ethical culture School in the film
Oppenheimer claims that the J in his
name didn't stand for anything the
biography of the film is based on
American premiere explains that it
wasn't common practice for Jewish
fathers to name their sons after
themselves however Julius added his own
name to his son's birth certificate at
the last second J Robert oppenheimer's
wealth distinguished him from other
Jewish Americans socially even though he
was generally indifferent about both
money and his Jewish Heritage while
growing up he was an odd child who was
bullied by his peers he skipped Graves
was obsessed with rocks and minerals and
was once violently hazed at summer camp
by his teenage years he was already
showing signs of both genius and
instability that's a lot of baggage for
one man it took me a minute to actually
comprehend and then I realized oh that's
a huge responsibility while studying at
Cambridge University Oppenheimer poisons
his professor's Apple after he's forced
to miss the beginning of a lecture and
clean up his sloppy lab work the real
Oppenheimer was notoriously clumsy with
his experiments which was why he ended
up working in theoretical physics that
poisoning was no creative flourish
either as Oppenheimer did indeed inject
his tutor Patrick blackett's apple with
chemicals and it caused more of a
scandal than what's shown in the movie
in the film Oppenheimer wakes up in a
panic the following morning and rushes
back to the classroom to find his Idol
Niels Bohr about to take a bite to
prevent a disaster he says that he
spotted a wormhole and tosses the Apple
in the trash in reality Oppenheimer was
struggling with more serious mental
illness his questionable perception of
reality led to a diagnosis of dementia
precox which is a now outdated term for
schizophrenia in the real version of the
misguided Revenge plot block it never
ate the apple Oppenheimer was neither
arrested nor expelled partly due to
conflicting accounts and his father's
influence the ordeal was seen as a cry
for help and he managed to seek
psychiatric care
audience is expecting to see a movie
about World War II may have been
surprised by how much of Oppenheimer is
instead about closed-door politics in
particular there are the grueling series
of hearings in which oppenheimer's
security clearance and loyalty to
America are called into question the
film ultimately remains ambiguous about
whether or not its subject was ever
officially a member of the Communist
Party suggesting instead that he was
most likely a leftist FDR supporter who
had associations with card carrying
Communists in American Prometheus
Oppenheimer is quoted as claiming that
he was so apolitical that he didn't know
about the stock market crash of 1929
until Ernest Lawrence told him six
months later and he never voted until
1936. his interest in and support of
left-wing causes began around 1934 and
continued until roughly the time he
became involved in war efforts
Oppenheimer insisted that he never
joined the Communist Party although he
did admit in writing I have been a
member of just about every Communist
front organization on the west coast
furthermore several of oppenheimer's
family members friends and acquaintances
were active Communists at certain points
in their lives
it feels to smell every single character
is significant because they're all
historical figures of consequence in the
movie Oppenheimer says that only a fool
or a child would presume to know what
goes on in a relationship he's talking
about his wife Kitty played by Emily
Blunt but the sentiment is even more
applicable to his romance with Jean
tatlock as portrayed by Florence Pugh
tatlock was studying to become a child
psychologist when she and Oppenheimer
met and bonded over their inner demons
and left-leaning ideologies the film
touches on their intense but relatively
short-lived relationship as well as one
final tryst followed by tatlock
committing suicide by Drowning herself
in a bathtub the truth is much more
complicated in the movie She's annoyed
at oppenheimer's habit of gift giving
but in real life she ended up regretting
her constant refusal of flowers and
marriage proposals she was also rumored
to have carried on an affair with her
communist friend Mary Ellen Washburn
Jean talock was blunt knew what she
wants but at no point is she ever
punished for that American Prometheus
contends that tatlock's suicide may not
have been a suicide at all when her
father discovered her body he burned
learned her letters before calling the
police it's been theorized that a
government official may have had her
killed out of fear that Oppenheimer
shared State secrets that she could have
passed on to the Russians Kitty
oppenheimer's incredible story is barely
touched upon in the film she's depicted
as an unhappy mother and jealous wife
with a moderate drinking problem but the
real Kitty was a more extreme version of
the one we see on screen the only child
of an upper-class German family Kitty
falsely claimed that she was a princess
she also frequently enrolled in colleges
but failed to take any classes she
divorced her first husband after
learning that he was gay and addicted to
drugs her second husband died in battle
and then she became pregnant with
oppenheimer's baby while she was married
to her third dating married women and
cheating on his wife wasn't unusual for
Oppenheimer he attempted to seduce his
secretary at Los Alamos and letters
showed that he had a long-term
relationship with Ruth Tolman the wife
of his friend Richard Tolman according
to American Prometheus Kitty was
resentful of her husband's lovers and
his Fame and alcoholic who got into
several car crashes and sustained Broken
Bones from Falls she favored liquor over
food at parties and frequently fell
asleep with lit cigarettes she may have
also suffered from postpartum depression
she had this Defiance against the system
that felt so modern the most accurate
part of Oppenheimer is likely the
section that takes place at Los Alamos
which lasts from 1942 to 1945. Leslie
Groves as played by Matt Damon recruits
Oppenheimer to head up the secret army
weapons lab the real Groves and
Oppenheimer had their disagreements but
they respected each other and worked
well together Groves wanted the
scientists to become soldiers and wear
uniforms but he conceded that they could
meet once a week to share ideas for the
sake of progress additionally Isador
Isaac Robbie did indeed decide to
consult rather than move west while
Edward Teller did indeed favor the
hydrogen bomb the technical specs are
more or less historically accurate as
well a cyclotron was used to accelerate
particles and the theorists did truly
fear that they made ignite the
atmosphere the uranium and plutonium
cores were about as big as represented
by the fishbowls filled with marbles the
bomb was referred to as the gadget so as
to minimize awareness of its purpose and
the crew was relieved to learn from
Niels Bohr that the Germans took a wrong
turn despite the Head Start that Werner
Heisenberg had given them but the film
doesn't portray how the U.S considered
having Heisenberg assassinated and
poisoning German food supplies and in
the movie Oppenheimer Whispers his
famous quote from the bhagavad-gita even
though he may have only thought it on
the day of now I am become death
destroyer of worlds in one key scene
Professor haken Chevalier played by
Jefferson Hall tells Oppenheimer that
the academic Community has been
complaining about Americans refusing to
share intelligence with their allies
including Russia he mentions that
another physicist named George eltonton
made it known that he could Channel such
information should anyone want to
divulge their secrets Oppenheimer says
that would be treason and Chevalier
changes the subject in real life
Oppenheimer did report eltonton but not
until sometime after chevalier's visit
instead he concocted a fake story to
protect his friend he admitted the truth
to Leslie Groves eventually but the fake
story came back to haunt him by
undermining his character during his
security clearance hearings in the end
chevalier's name came out anyway and he
was blacklisted after that he moved to
France to work as a translator for his
part he maintained that he was simply
alerting Oppenheimer to elton's scheme
rather than soliciting nuclear Intel as
the movie hurdles toward its climax
Oppenheimer and Josh hartnett's Ernest
Lauren attend a Department of Defense
meeting to discuss whether and where to
drop the atomic bombs prior to this
meeting some of the scientists at Los
Alamos had begun to discuss the ethics
of the weapons Oppenheimer assured them
that public awareness could be
terrifying enough to end all wars behind
closed doors some wonder if a
demonstration might be enough or if
civilians should be warned in advance
the military shoots down these ideas
though as they would jeopardize the
mission and the safety of the pilots the
group chooses two Targets out of 11
possibilities with Kyoto being withdrawn
from consideration because Secretary of
War Henry stimpson honeymooned there
these details are all true Oppenheimer
had much less power once the A-bomb had
been invented and the scientific
Community had begun to question its
necessity Germany had already
surrendered and Hitler had killed
himself Japan was likely to surrender in
the coming months if they were permitted
to keep their Emperor although
unconditional surrender was preferable
Oppenheimer defended the decision to
drop the bombs throughout his life
although he did tell President Harry
Truman that he felt he had blood on his
hands as he does in the film
if there's a villain in Oppenheimer it's
Louis Strauss he's depicted as a
vindictive man who has it out for
Oppenheimer because he embarrassed him
during the debate about the export of
Isotopes and stood in the way of the
development of hydrogen bombs he was a
righteous guy I think it was a great
public servant but he's always behind
the scenes I've always appreciated the
people who are backstage in real life
there was even more animosity
Oppenheimer and Strauss were as similar
as they were different both were the
sons of German Jewish immigrant
businessmen but a recession hit
strauss's family harder both were smart
and ambitious with plans to study
Physics but Strauss couldn't afford to
continue his education Oppenheimer was
liberal while Strauss was conservative
and Oppenheimer was secular while
Strauss was religious Strauss
orchestrated the demise of oppenheimer's
reputation but he also brought about his
own ruin in the process three votes
including that of Senator John F Kennedy
made the difference as he failed to be
appointed as Secretary of Commerce
Oppenheimer ends with a fictional scene
involving Albert Einstein whom Lewis
Strauss had long believed that
Oppenheimer had turned against him a
senate aide played by Alden ehrenreich
tells him that maybe they were
discussing something more important when
we finally see that conversation play
out Einstein talks about Awards while
Oppenheimer expresses his belief that he
set off an Unstoppable chain reaction
with the Advent of nuclear power
Einstein and Oppenheimer did indeed know
each other and Oppenheimer did indeed
receive a medal it was the Enrico Fermi
award for his contributions to physics
and it was widely seen as an apology for
his treatment during the McCarthy era
later in life Oppenheimer continued to
speak out about the threat of nuclear
war and in favor of international
cooperation but he was never the same
after the humiliation he suffered when
his loyalty was questioned and his
clearance was revoked he and kitty lived
part-time in the Virgin Islands where he
rediscovered his love of sailing a
lifelong smoker Oppenheimer died of
throat cancer in 1967 at the age of 62.
[Music]
thank you